so X plus cos x the Zen driven off the
top my head what result was what do we
get through to the rear was out our
that's easy what's the amplitude its
route to so I'm changing this it's it's
sine plus course resides at the front so
if I can choose any for my line output
side at the front this is a plus right
so it's going to be X plus and what was
the angle what's alpha plan for right
and you got that from a and B are both
one so cos alpha will be one on root 2
and sine alpha will be one on root 2 so
those where you plan for culture so this
is equal to 1 okay so you can get this
and now how do we go about simplifying
it spider by virtue
okay now just like I did before
I changed the way I said my domain to
make sure I got the right solutions yeah
so I went from X to excellent su you do
the same thing here because this
function is not in terms of just X
either it takes one for right so now I
want my middle in terms of expert on
four so that means I add pile for to
both or every part of the inequality
okay so I'm thinking of buying for two
that to two pi plus PI over 4 which is 9
ok good so now when I think what
solutions can I get for this well again
this is a an exact value and it's exact
value for what they single what's the
what's the acute angle that fits one of
you to this platform right so I'm
getting X was fired for being equal to
solution one okay and does that check
out within the domain yes
just barely okay what's the next
solution are going to expect one
that's the other solution for next
it's going to be pi - make you think
about in terms of quadrants if you like
so a s - see it's positive since PI -
which is 3 PI over 4 as you said ok but
I'm sorry start again
I'd usually be finished at that point
you got two solutions no problems ok but
my third term 8 is a little different
right so in fact this first bit is not
included because it's 0 to pi/4 and i
have to add the little extra bit okay
and that little extra bit happens to
matter because it just gets you to the
angle that you want
so what's that angle it's writing into
the dilute one to three solutions that
fit my domain and I want it just in
terms of X so I'll take pond four away
from everything back using 0 to pi/4 -
ok now in this case I mean we generally
go with T results to say it sort of
makes things simpler I think in this
example but it doesn't really like or
exhibiting angle is just superior way to
go about this ok
but you still need to be able to
recognize both of them and sometimes
I'll stipulate you should